سيد محمد عبد السلام تعليقكم بدايه على
هذا الاعلان الامريكي باعتبار
وادراج الحوثيين كمنظمه ارهابيه
عالميه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم لم يكن مثل
هذا التوجه مفاجئ بالنسبه لنا لاننا ندرك
ان امريكا جندت نفسها لخدمه اسرائيل
ولاعطاء اسرائيل المزيد من الوقت والمساحه
لقتل الشعب الفلسطيني والمزيد من حصاره
وارتكاب المجازر بحقه ومن ارتكب المج ايضا
باليمن وشن المئات من الغارات والصواريخ
ليس بعيدا ان ياتي ليمثل او ليقدم مثل هذا
التصنيف نحن نعتقد ان امريكا تستخدم
التصنيف لاغراض سياسيه لما يخدم مصالحها
ليس لديها اي معايير قانونيه اذا كان احد
يستطيع ان يصنف احد بالارهاب فهو الارهاب
الصهيوني الاسرائيلي الذي يبل يوميا
بالمئات من ابناء فلسطين واطفالها ولهذا
نحن نعتقد انه لا يوجد لديهم اي مبرر لان
موقفنا من فلسطين موقف ديني واخلاقي
وانساني ومبدئي وهو مسانده الشعب
الفلسطيني المظلوم الذي تريد امريكا ان
يقتل بد من بارد وان لا يقم احد بموقف ما
قام به اليمن هو هو استهداف السفن
الاسرائيليه او المتجهه الى اسرائيل كنوع
من الضغط والحصار على اسرائيل ولم يصل
الامر الى القتل وانما من باب الضغط على
الصهاينه للتوقف عن استمرار جرائمهم بحق
الشعب الفلسطيني ومع ذلك امريكا ومن يقف
معها يضيق ضاقوا ذرعا بهذا الموقف واتجهوا
لمثل هذا التصنيف ولهذا انا اؤكد ان هذا
التصنيف لن يثني اليمن عن المواصله في
موقفها المساند لفلسطين وللمظلوم في قطاع
غزه المحاصرين ولا يمكن الا ان ان يزيد
اليمنيين قوه وصلابه وتمسكا بهذا الموقف
المشروع والمسؤول والمنسجم حتى مع القانون
الدولي موقفكم ثابت كما ذكرت سيد محمد م
عبد السلام ولكن هل تعتقدون ان يكون لهذا
الاعلان اي تاثيرات على المستوى الانساني
على اقل تقدير في هذا التوقيت على اليمن
الذي يعاني اوضاعا انسانيه صعبه ويخص طبعا
البعد الاقتصادي التجاري
والانساني اليمن بالاساس هو يخضع لحصار
اقتصادي من قبل امريكا منذ سنوات استه
استهدف النظام المصرفي في اليمن منذ سنوات
قام امريكا بنقل البنك المركزي ودعمت نقل
البنك المركزي واغلاق السويفت ومحاصر
الصرافين ليس هذا جديد بالنسبه للوضع
الاقتصادي ولا حتى للوضع العسكري امريكا
لم تكن في وفاق مع الشعب اليمني وانها
جاءت اليوم لتغير قواعد اللعبه امريكا
اصلا كانت تستهدفها عسكريا وتستهدف هنا
اقتصاديا وتستهدف هنا سياسيا وتستهدف هنا
انسانيا وهي من قامت حتى بمعاقبه الكثير
من الصرافين والكثير من من شركات الاقتصاد
في اليمن نتيجه انها تقوم بعمل او خدمات
في صنعاء ولذلك نحن من حيث الفاعليه على
الارض اؤكد انه لا فاعليه لهذا القرار على
الاطلاق لانها جاءت جاء التصنيف متاخرا
وقد سبقه كل ما يستلزم التصنيف من اجراءات
قد جاءتنا مسبقا عبر سنوات سابقه لهذا نحن
لا نعتقد ان هذا جديد ولن يؤثر باعتبار
انه نحن اصلا في حاله التاثير وهذا شيء
مؤسف ان امريكا اظهرت على الاقل وجهها
الحقيقي تجاه اليمن اليوم بشكل واضح
واعادت ما يسمى بالتصنيف من اجل فقط اعطاء
بعدا ذات دافع انتخابي داخل امريكا اكثر
من ان يكون له واقع على الارض لانها قد
قصفت الجمهوريه اليمنيه بالصواريخ وب
الغواصات وبالباترون الاجرام والارهاب نعم
القرار س يتم تنفيذه بعد 30 يوم من اعلانه
ما الذي انتم بصدد فعله كل هذه
الفتره اولا بالنسبه لموقف هنا مع فلسطين
انا اؤكد انه لن لن يتراجع على الاطلاق
باستهداف السفن الاسرائيليه او السفن
المتجهه الى موانئ فلسطين المحتله ثم نحن
ايضا كقوات مسلحه مدعومه من كل اليمنيين
وليس فقط انصار الله هم يؤيدون ويقفون الى
جانب القياده والقوات المسلحه في دعمها في
هذا الموقف ولهذا نحن لن نتراجع لن تراجع
هذا امر مفروغ منه وهو قرار اتخذه الشعب
اليمني ونعتبره اقل قرار يمكن لمسانده
الشعب الفلسطيني المظلوم الذي يقف للاسف
اغلب الانظمه اما متفرجه او ساكته الامر
الاخر نحن لا نريد هذا التصنيف في كل
الاحوال ولسنا نحن ممن يطبل لمثل هذا نحن
لا نريد هذا التصنيف ونتمنى ان يكون هناك
موقف شعبي يمني وشعبي عربي واسلامي لرفض
هذه الهمجيه الامريكيه التي تريد اسكات كل
الاصوات الحره والتي تتحرك بفاعليه
لمواجهه البربريه الصهيونيه اضافه الى ذلك
زادنا هذا الموقف وسيزيد هنا تمسكا
بموقفنا الاخلاقي والانساني في دعم
اخواننا في فلسطين ولا يمكن ان نتراجع في
في في هذا الاتجاه اما من اي اجراءات اخرى
قد تتخذها امريكا سواء في التصعيد العسكري
او في مزيد من الاستهداف داخل اليمن فان
القوات المسلحه بصدد الرد وهي قد قامت
بعمليات رد ايضا واستهدفت ايضا السفن
المرتبطه بالامريكي والبري انيين باعتبار
العمليات العسكريه التي قاموا بها ولهذا
نحن لا يوجد لدينا خيار اصلا سواء في فتره
30 يوم اقلت ام كثرت لا خيار لدينا لان ما
نقوم به هو موقف محب ومسؤول فالذي يجب ان
يتراجع خلال هذه الفتره هو الامريكي وعليه
ان يراجع حسابه وان يدرك انه يصنف 50 او
40 مليون من ابناء اليمن ليس موقف انصار
الله هو موقف كل الاحرار في اليمن بل موقف
كل الاحرار في المنطقه والعالم باسره الذي
قد ضج من هذه المجازر الوحشيه التي
ترتكبها اسرائيل وناسف ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تقف ساكته وداعمه في
مجلس الامن للوقوف بحزم امام اي قرار
يطالب بوقف العدوان في غزه الحل هل تبتم
سيد محمد عبد السلام ما تم تداوله عبر
منصات اعلاميه وسائل اعلام امريكيه من ان
خطوط الامداد كما تقول الولايات المتحده
بينكم وبين ايران بعد الخطوات والضربات
الامريكيه البريطانيه للحوثيين في اليمن
قد قطعت كيف تردون على
ذلك هذا كلام غير دقيق لعده اعتبارات اولا
اليمن هو في يخرج من حرب لتسع سنوات
تقريبا كان الامريكي والبريطاني مشاركين
فيها بشكل او باخر الى جانب الامارات
والسعوديه ودول اخرى ولهذا كل ما يقوله
الامريكي اليوم بل وكل ما قصفه الامريكي
داخل اليمن قد تم قصفه مسبقا وقد سمعنا عن
قاعده الديلمي وقد سمعنا عن الكثير من
القواعد ومنصات الصواريخ كما اننا ايضا اب
تمعنا عن التدخل الايراني والسفن
الايرانيه والتهريب وما الى ذلك نحن نؤكد
اننا في هذا المضمار متوكلون على الله
ومستمد العون منه تعالى لاننا في قضيه
محقه وعادله سنواجه كافه التحديات في في
كل الاتجاهات سواء كانت على المستوى
السياسي وعلى المستوى العسكري وعلى
المستوى الاعلامي وعلى المستوى التضليلي
ايضا ولن تؤثر حتى لا يوجد هناك خطوط
امداد كما يقدمها الامريكي باعتبار ان
هناك جسرا لا جويا ولا بحريا بين اليمن
وايران وكلما هناك هو في الغالب ياتي
ليمسك الكثير من الزوارق التي تكون في
العاده لتجار يمنيين لان التجاره بالسلاح
في اليمن مفتوحه ومع هذا نحن نقول هذا
تحدي نحن لا نمانع ان ندخل فيه وفي
مواجهته وال الدفع به وفي مواجهته للتغلب
على كل الخيارات التي قد تطرا اليها
امريكا وحلفائها تقول بانه تحدي ولكن على
ماذا تعول جماعه الحوثي في هذه
المرحله نحن كما عولنا في السابق في اغلب
التحديات عولنا على الله سبحانه وتعالى
وعلى مظلوميته المحجه او قضيتنا العادله
وعلى شعبنا اليمني العظيم الذي يخرج
بالملايين في الساحات كل اسبوع في مسيرات
ربما لا يخرج لها نظير او مثيل في اي مكان
اخر ولهذا نحن نستند على الله ونستند ايضا
على مظلوميه الشعب اليمني في مواجهه
مظلوميه في الغطرسه الامريكيه للمسانده
الشعب الفلسطيني شكرا لك محمد عبد سلام
المتحدث باسم انصار الله الحوثيين الان